julie back to the war right now we'll
tell you what happened over the weekend
now here is the the areas contested by
the russian army are all in red one of
the more significant stories happened
over here in the west you see how close
this is now
with the polish border this has been a
training area facility used by nato
forces you've had a lot of congressional
delegations visited this site as well
35 people killed in cruise missile
strikes now
several of them many more were knocked
from the sky but some did hit their
target at this training center last week
lev is where a lot of our reporters have
been stationed last week you might
remember there was an attack about 90
miles of the southeast and 90 miles to
the northeast by the russian military as
well advance at one time here this is
the city center of kiev what is
significant about what happened the last
24 hours
this is the main air base right that was
putin's plan he was going to take the
air base he was going to invade keeve
that did not go to plan instead they've
been trying to hammer these
neighborhoods to the northwest and
hammer the neighborhoods to the east now
this however is a new development this
is an aircraft production facility just
northwest of town that was hit overnight
as well we'll see
what sort of putin strategy has to do
with this
in the coming days in the south well a
couple of things i think of significance
just to note since we left off from last
friday odessa has not been touched why
is that ton of theories catherine the
great 1795 one of putin's heroes maybe
maybe not is an explanation for that
mikolai
this is a town that is getting repeated
bombardments not to the level of what we
have seen in mary opal in the east
but still you can see the video in the
tanks just hitting apartment buildings
indiscriminately mario pole is a death
scene we know that and melatopal is
something what's very interesting
happened over the weekend just go ahead
and we'll pan over and show you uh to
the top of your screen
in the shadow that
that's the mayor of the town who was led
away
by russian forces that was on friday so
what's happened since then over the
weekend well there were thousands in the
streets that were protesting video again
jimmy over here on the screen
there were thousands who came out to
protest his abduction
so there are ukrainians living in these
cities who are voicing their um
strong disagreements for what's
happening in their town as we speak
today